[Music]
in Toronto's High Park people are
gathering for a unique musical
performance something involving
these
mushrooms they're not the magic kind but
they will enhance the
[Music]
mood
in mushrooms you just never know what
you're going to get sometimes you plug
in and they're going nuts and sometimes
nothing happens for minutes you know and
then it will just go crazy
again it's a fungi
feature and the conductor of this earthy
Orchestra is Tun
nyer a trained biologist and working
musician I who harmonizes his passions
plugging into whatever he finds growing
outside his home in the northern Gulf
islands of British
Columbia in the Pacific Northwest fall
is the time for mushrooms and I was like
might as well plug into a
mushroom and that's exactly what he does
sending a small electric current through
the mushroom the changes in resistance
are converted into various rhythms and
Melodies on his
synthesizer everything around us has
electrical properties and you can use
the fluctuations and the electrical
properties of the organic world to
inform art and
conversation he's played around with
hundreds of mushrooms over the last
couple of years and learned a lot more
about them in no small part because of
one of his neighbors I mean I never
thought of that if mushrooms are the
instruments Paul stamitz is their
maestro
[Music]
a self-described citizen scientist who's
been fascinated by fungi for over 40
years mushrooms are like miniature
biochemical factories some can feed you
some can heal you some can kill you some
can send you on a spiritual
journey he shot to fame for being a
proponent of siloc cybin the Magic in
those magic mushrooms but his work on
the non psychedelic powers of mushrooms
is just as
mind-blowing like how mushrooms can
protect bee
colonies the melum helps the immunity of
the bees to fight
viruses and Paul believes mushrooms have
other worldly capabilities
too he's working with NASA to see if
fungi can create healthy soil out of the
asteroid dust on
Mars while they have potential in space
mushrooms are deeply rooted in the earth
if you were to lift up the forest floor
you'd find their Roots melium everywhere
small white threads spreading out like
spider webs providing an important
Network for plants and trees
communicating where food and water can
be found a kind of ecological
internet These Fine threads that are
under every footstep that you take up to
hundreds of miles they are part of the
immune system of our
planet even though we consume them like
vegetables fungi are not plants or
animals or bacteria they exist as their
very own kingdom there are more than 1.5
million species out there yet only 10%
have actually been
identified Canadian farmers are having a
Field Day sales have mushroomed 20%
since 2018
Patty Smith co-founder of Whistler
Harvest has a front row seat to the
fungi frenzy you've seen the demand for
them grow so to speak we cannot grow
enough or keep enough on the shelves
because it just goes so
quickly Patty grows most of his
mushrooms indoors but some can only be
obtained in the
[Music]
wild that's where Patty's partner Paul
Kane comes in definitely secretive you
won't find many people willing to share
their spots I've never forged before and
figured this was as good a time as any
how do you know what you're looking for
I I was taught at a very young age to
learn to identify the trees opposed to
actually look for the mushrooms on the
ground so instead of looking down yeah
yeah look up and if you learn to
identify what mushrooms associate with
the different tree species you'll have a
lot more success
right here growing on this mountain
Hemlock is what's called chicken of the
woods or the sulfur shelf mushroom and
this is a choice edible widely consumed
by households chefs absolutely love this
mushroom there are so many varieties on
our plates these days but the
versatility of mushrooms goes well
beyond the kitchen some can actually
help the planet recover from Eco
disasters melium eats oil and then it
can transform it into something that's
nutritious to see that process in action
we went to northern BC where residents
here in Hazelton are testing out
mushrooms on a long-standing problem
involving salmon and the
railroad Canadian National Railway runs
through this vital fish habitat known as
the SK
Watershed the SK is BC 's second largest
salmon Watershed and it's just over
54,000 square km which is bigger than
Switzerland Shannon mcfa is co-executive
director of The sko Watershed
conservation
Coalition it has all five species of
wild salmon we also have the largest
strain of wild steel head in the
world but that ecosystem is threatened
because of a chemical found in the rail
ties creosote a toxic substance that's
been used since the 1800s to preserve
the
wood when ties wear out they're removed
from the tracks and piled beside the
railway by the thousands sometimes for
decades where the chemicals can leech
into the soil they just leave them there
the only time they remove them is either
they're going to bring them elsewhere to
bury them or burn them and that just
adds to the problem it doesn't cure the
problem Chief neox is the hereditary
chief for the woin he says it's the duty
of his people to protect the SK
Watershed we don't have major
development on our Rivers it is pristine
we can drink out of our Rivers out of
our Creeks out of our lakes and we've
ensured that there are not many places
on this planet you could do that the US
Environmental Protection Agency has
identified creosote as a carcinogen that
may pose risks to fish and
invertebrates I read all these case
studies where they used oyster mushrooms
to clean up oil or diesel or other
fossil fuel spills in the ground and
then you were able to eat the mushrooms
after it was really really interesting
and that kind of blew my mind and it I
thought it that can't actually work can
it Shannon's Coalition set out to
investigate teaming up with Farmers
Chris coula and Martin hmel to test the
theory oh wow melium can be trained to
eat certain kinds of wood in this case
pieces of rail
ties you have a bit of railroad tie and
then we took little pieces off it and
then put it on the Peter dish put the
mum culture on it we tried Elm Moyers
turkey tail artist conch chicken of the
woods the Victorious mushroom was turkey
tail it consumed the creosote converting
it back into its non-toxic base elements
we need to do a lot more testing but
what we know at the start is that the
worst we can do is we can make these
very toxic Railway ties significantly
less toxic an exciting first step now
the next one is testing it on a much
larger scale moving from the petri dish
to the piles of ties and that requires
the cooperation of Cen Railway we'd love
Cen to come in as a partner and actually
help deal with this because their toxic
Legacy in this region needs to shift
Shannon says CN has has been contacted
but so far has not agreed to any further
development with the remediation project
CN did not respond to Global News
request for comment and the frustrating
part is we shouldn't have to depend on a
nonprofit small organization in
Northwestern in Hazelton to have to do
this work but this is our
home from Nature's
cleaner to foraged
music
to
tabletop there's a mushroom cloud of
possibilities on the
horizon and new reasons to elevate those
little forest dwellers beneath our feet
y mushrooms have become the Zeitgeist of
our time mushrooms check every box and
bringing people together in
community sharing their ancestral
knowledge also it's exciting mushrooms
are colorful they're beautiful
mysterious they're
[Music]
fun after all the first three letters of
fungi is
fun